hope
and we're leaving that interview a
little early ashraf ghani the former
afghan president uh talking to the
people of his country indeed the broader
region indeed the world all the
countries that had a strategic interest
in his
uh country via his facebook live page
let's listen in to what he's saying
and that was the main purpose of the
goal
it was developments took place
very fast
my purpose was to work
with the taliban to
reach a conclusion for a comprehensive
government through
on sunday i was following
routine
schedule
and i was working
on order and discipline for kabul
security officials
advise me to get away from those
circumstances basically to be away from
the circumstances
to keep a distance
in their hands under control
how well
i would have been witnessing bloodshed
in kabul
there's a poor quality of sound
unfortunately the voice is breaking up
my mission was going to be
for power
seeking
kabul should not be turned into another
yemen or syria
after i was forced to leave
a number of people who entered the
presidential palace arc who could not
even speak our national languages
they were looking for to find me
what
what had happened 25 years ago in
afghanistan was going to take place
again
i had to
leave afghanistan
an order
in order to
understand
make sure
that a huge disaster is prevented
understandable
after
i've fled the country
my message is
that you should not judge if you do not
have the actual information and details
there's going to be another stage
those who say that your presence
that's
there was some
documents confidential documents that
actually
unfortunately
were left
there
and they're now in the hands of others
and i did not take anything with me
just with wow one
shallower and chemise
and one waistcoat i had to leave the
country
[Music]
i support them until the process is
completed
when it comes to the political
leadership
of the taliban
it was a failure on their part and a
failure on our part that the
negotiations did not lead
to anything
the
actually
anticipated
that the
negotiations amongst afghans should be
african-led
currently i'm in the uae
so that
disasters are avoided i'm in
consultation
uh
with others
until i returned
and until so that i could continue my
efforts for justice
for the afghans
and to achieve
the achievements the real islamic and
national achievements of the people of
afghanistan so that we could
fight for them together thank you very
much
for all the messages
and sympathies
that you have sent
thank you very much lovely long live
afghanistan apologies for that
short and sweet address there uh via his
facebook live page from ashraf ghani uh
the former now uh president of
afghanistan uh let's just take you
through what he had to say he was
talking for what maybe
ten minutes i guess just a little over
10 minutes a very very
personal address to the people of
afghanistan the broader region the
international community talking about
just that immediate time that period of
time when he decided to leave the
countries that events took place very
fast my purpose had been to pave the way
for a transition as of since sunday
working on uh order for kabul his
security people advised him to get away
if he'd stayed
he would have witnessed bloodshed
in kabul the people of kabul have
witnessed bloodshed because there has
been bloodshed in kabul the city of
course he didn't say that that's me
saying that and in the the province of
kabul as well he said he was forced to
leave what took place before was going
to happen again he said referring to the
events of i guess the 1980s 1990s up to
the point when the taliban were banished
many details need to be provided i guess
he's teasing us a little bit there he
said he had to leave his main assets and
confidential
documents he described the process going
on around him now as a personality
assassination he said it's baseless he
said he thanked the defense forces
political leadership of the taliban and
the political leadership of afghanistan
failed the people
of afghanistan listening to all of that
for us as ever was our diplomatic editor
james bayes james no message to the
people of afghanistan no reading
or no kind of descriptive language as if
he seems to understand or not the
enormity of what's happening
just his justification for why he left
and why he fled afghanistan he actually
said there i didn't flee afghanistan but
everyone is aware that's exactly what
happened also trying to justify how he
left because remember there have been
numerous allegations that he left with
suitcases full of cash in fact the
afghan um
embassy in tajikistan as they were
taking down his picture in the embassy
were demanding interpol arrest him uh
there have been demands also the russian
special um
special adviser on afghanistan has said
recently ambassador kabalov that perhaps
the afghan people should put ashraf
ghani on trial and i think he's trying
to defend himself he said certainly that
he did he only went because he was
forced by his security officials and
then he claimed that as soon as he left
people actually came to the presidential
palace looking for him there's nothing
that we can find i think at this stage
to support that claim certainly we
understand that he left with two close
officials with
hamdullah muhib who was his national
security adviser and faisal faisali who
was the director of administrative
affairs in the presidential palace very
two people very close to hamid karzai
but peter it's worth telling you that
most of the others in the government
sorry close to ashraf ghani it's worth
telling you that most of the others
in the presidential palace and among the
cabinet are really um despising the
former president now and it was i think
pretty true even a couple of weeks ago
as you know i was in kabul a couple of
weeks ago i spent a little bit of time
in the presidential palace i spoke to
senior members
of the ghani government to former
ministers as well and there wasn't
really much of a good word to be said
about ashraf ghani and clearly the way
he's held
in afghanistan has got worse since the
way he departed afghanistan he of course
denying that he took suitcases of cash
saying he just took his showa comes his
traditional afghan robes and uh afghan
shirt and left and left kabul he's
turned up we believe in the united arab
emirates we think in dubai uh will we
hear anything more from ashraf ghani i
think it seems very unlikely despite he
says there'll be another episode that
he's going to play any important role in
the future of afghanistan now is he also
slightly misinterpreting the events that
took place over the past what
particularly the last week james maybe
the last two weeks when he said what
happened should have led to an end to
the war because whilst yes it was being
labeled particularly where you are by
some of the american networks as being a
war another war in afghanistan
there were large areas where it was
actually more of a drive-by shooting on
the part of the taliban because the
afghan security apparatus was turning
tail and running it was taking off its
uniforms or it was even being kind of
subscripted if you will or subscribed
into being part of the taliban
absolutely such surprising events and
such speed to all of that he may have
been referring to that i think he's also
possible he was referring to to what
should have happened to the peace deal
because remember the u.s did sign a
peace deal
did sign a peace deal with the taliban
and there was supposed to be a
negotiated settlement between the
government of afghanistan
and the taliban and of course it didn't
end like that it ended in a military way
with the taliban uh taking control of
the situation on the ground in kabul
he's certainly not the president now and
even his vice president who's still in
afghanistan
he says he is now uh the caretaker uh
president of afghanistan and it's
interesting that amr saleh the vice
president is in panshir that's a small
province of afghanistan just a little
finger of territory but it's the one
little bit of afghanistan that hasn't at
this stage been properly controlled uh
by the taliban and ruler saleh who i
don't think was in a sort of tactical um
coalition with ashraf ghani but i don't
think would be described as one of his
close allies says he's going to uh
continue fighting against the taliban
for now though pretty clear who is in
pretty much total control of most of the
country and that is the taliban james as
ever a pleasure many thanks uh james
bayes our diplomatic editor there at the
u.n in new york ashraf ghani the former
president of afghanistan saying as well
i am proud of what we have done i'm in
the uae so disasters are avoided we are
in consultations with others i want to
achieve real achievements for
afghanistan he said
[Music]
1730g your top stories
as we've been on air this half hour the
former president of afghanistan ashraf
ghani has just spoken to the afghan
people via his facebook live page from
where he's staying right now the united
arab emirates there had been confusion
about his whereabouts since he left the
country on sunday the uae says he's been
taken in with his family on humanitarian
grounds
taliban fighters have reportedly opened
fire on protesters in the eastern afghan
city of jalalabad three people are said
to have been killed and several others
were wounded
gunfire has also been heard during
protests in the eastern city of coast
there has been no immediate reporting of
any injuries demonstrators raised the
afghan national flag over a road in the
city taliban fighters were then seen
chasing crowds away rob mcbride is in
kabul
this was a particularly ugly incident
and i think it's being seen as really
since the taliban just assumed power a
couple of days ago as the first major
active defiance against them uh
jalalabad is a very important city it is
east of here towards the border with uh
pakistan and this protest began over the
national flag now since the taliban have
taken power they have very consciously
been removing the afghan national flag
and replacing it with the taliban flag
we've seen that a lot here in the
capital kabul it's left a lot of people
are very upset